people may experience various
difficulties in writing blogs articles
or corporates for example some may
struggle to find a time to sit down and
write something out or they may struggle
to get a creative ideas flowing and
think of something new and interesting
to write about whatever the difficulty
is but it is essential to move around
and try to write something that you are
proud of it may not be perfect but it is
unique to you and can be a great way to
express yourself so if you are looking
for a free AI writing tool that will
automate your articles blogs or
copyrights Etc you have come to the
right place this video will introduce
you to a top 5 free AI writing tools
available today on that note welcome to
simple if you are new to the Channel
please subscribe to our simply learn
YouTube channel and click the Bell icon
to be the first one to know about the
latest trending videos now without
further delay let's see the top 5 free
AI writing tools or websites the first
one is brighter me writer is an AI
writing tool that can generate many
different types of content this can be
used for website copywriting creating
marketing and sales copy writing full
blog post and menu here you can generate
10 000 characters per month which means
you can write up to 10 000 characters
every month and once your 10 000
characters of that particular month is
completed it will be restored in the
next month and personally I recommend
this tool to write any types of
copywriting the link below in the
description will directly take you to
the writers free plan sign up to the
website and enjoy the free plan of right
and the second one is jasper.ai Jasper
can write original content creatively
including blogs articles social media
Post website copy Etc to claim a free
access to Jasper please click on the
link in the description here you can
clean up to 10 000 words for free that
is you can write up to 10 000 words
available in its replay most of the
people don't use their free trial of
Jasper because while logging into the
website it will ask for the credit card
number but you can use the credit card
number because unless and until you
complete your free trial and shift to
premium the money won't be deducted if
you like the feature of Jasper you can
continue with the premium if not log out
from the website and the third one is
right zone right Sonic is an AI powered
copyright tool that will generate a
unique and engaging marketing content
for any types of business in seconds
with a few lines of text right Sonic
will generate ads blog posts landing
pages product description and menu here
you will get a free trial for all the
features with 650 words per user once
you are done with the free trial you can
opt the Premium plan which is available
for 12.67 where you will get 40 500
words per user the link mentioned Below
in the description will directly take
you the free plan of bright Sonic and
the fourth one is right click the right
crime is a creative AI powered marketing
tool that utilize the advanced machine
learning to write a copy of Google ads
landing pages product descriptions blog
post social media and menu here you will
get up to 20 credits that is 40 000
characters in which you can write two
long articles of 5000 words and four
short articles of thousand words if you
are comfortable with the right cream you
can go for its Premium plan which
charges 29 dollars per month and right
cream as an amazing offer of getting all
these features for Lifetime only for 59
and the last one is scale it is the
combination of Next Generation
Technologies like Ai and NLP and the
seamless content creation process to
create a Content that exits the rest it
enables you to improve your dates
readability efficiency and overall
output you can get a trial of scalar by
clicking on the link below in the
description here you will get 2000 words
40 plus AI tools two SEO reports and
menu you can also go for the Premium
plan for 924 rupees per month with this
we have reached the end of this session
today we'll learn top 5 aerating tools
that will help you write any copywriting
please like this video and share with
your friends for more such videos you
regarding this topic mention it in the
comment box and also do let me know
which is your favorite AI rating too in
the comment section thank you keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here